[MUSIC]
Systems Research is the foundation
innovation grows from.
It is a science where technology expands the
state of the art in computing infrastructure.
And that's what will be explored and
discussed August 1st and 2nd at the
Microsoft Research Faculty Summit 2018—
Systems | Fueling Future Disruptions.
At the Research Faculty Summit,
systems discussion will include
the intelligent edge, where IoT and the cloud
converge for low latency applications, and breakthrough
innovations like DNA, glass,
and how underwater datacenters
are being used for long term
and low cost cloud storage.
You’ll hear how researchers are envisioning
self-tuning AI systems and not just quantum computers
but quantum systems. Plus, you’ll learn more about the
exploration of confidential computing and trends in
blockchain technologies.
It’s the future revealed. Be part of it.
Go to www.microsoftfacultysummit.com
to register for keynotes live streamed
on August 1st and 2nd.